hey hey when I hit that there was some
fun stuff in it shabih you laugh you
lose
YouTube's favorite show everybody smash
that like button right now to join in on
the challenge yes that's the only way
you can watch this video and make sure
you smash twice and to subscribe smash
that like button to subscribe right now
to this channel oh that's so great I
think we show this one alright I'm not
sure it's subtle I didn't get it the
first time I saw it I'm like I don't
what's the big deal
[Music]
me and my dad will get that for our
wedding that's beautiful Oh what the
hell is this
[Applause]
please stop okay
not interested what I didn't say
anything what people pay to watch this
are you kidding me I do it for free
okay what the heck dude I don't care you
copy stretch my video
fault you brought this upon yourself
okay it's all your fault
no don't know how to give you a chance
to apologize
there's no reasoning in you Jesus Christ
that seems like a great show would love
to watch that that would just be
fanatics who live in our finale her
goeth met their bombs youthful fancy
boars grunting boars good old modern
warfare quickscope ever
[Applause]
why's our Swedish in there are the
sweets trying to infiltrate this show
Scott the roofer Lulu man-cake
it's a hard that is bare command
everybody hello I am a Swedish that is
gun come come I cannot believe he just
said that word did he did he just say
the T word the T word no that foul list
of all words this can't be right I must
find this video we immediately oh that's
so good I mean that's so awful uh
basically left and right politics
summarize right here uh whether a Quay
excuse me Gloria Borger here I don't
understand how beauty packet thing
thought was a me mobile work
hey that's completely beyond me how dare
he how dare he he used such foul
language it's not like people using
jokingly without a bad connotation all
the time doesn't make any sense
the recoil bruised my shoulder the
breath shell casings disoriented me as
they flew past my face this is an
article the smells the real article and
destruction made me sick the explosions
loud like a bomb gave me a temporary
case of PTSD Oh for at least an hour
after firing the gun just a few times I
was irritable
can you imagine gave you PTSD a
temporary form of PTSD temporary form
the dumbest thing I've ever heard to
make up like shooting a gun gave you
temporary PTSD if you've never been in a
war it makes absolutely no sense oh my
god I've seen this spoilers spoilers
[Music]
I love the guy that cracks up listen to
his laugh it's like a serious I can only
imagine the discussions they must have
had internally about the fact that
Pikachu all the sudden I don't know
where just decides to communicate in
English who's all adults in the cinema
as well watching this kids movie what
losing a sense as your shield alright
okay that's a defense deep his heads
deep its come on see oh she saw Dan when
they said come on you can do it sister
girl just a person like you it's a good
job she's gonna laugh come on are you
losing this opportunity what's the worst
they're gonna happen she's gonna like
you come on you can do it say it it's a
defense
it's a defense everyone press F from
their keyboard right now please all
right let's uh let's check the sims 3
kleptomaniac Sims can no longer steal
subway stations from Lots Sims can no
longer whoo-hoo and in the elevator with
a symbol different floor the grim reaper
will no longer be prevented from reaping
souls due to pay and affiliation fixed a
tuning issues so that sims now it is no
longer possible to try for baby sims who
are on fire will no longer be forced to
alonger a secret wish to skinny-dip with
mummies i'm here you can hit a building
which case everyone will run out before
the collision those who do not exit the
building will die sims automatically
leave if a meteor is approaching unless
it is a school this seams patch no
that's brilliant when you forget you
don't have a floor in your room
great fantastic well I heard a floor it
said I don't know what this meme is all
about well everybody that's hope you
guys enjoyed this video if you did make
sure to hit that Bell make sure to bring
it into gear from one sit in the right
order make sure wait wait us to make
sure to smash that Bell yank that lever
twist that knob pull that rod flip that
switch aerate that garage touch that
dial and you don't touch that now peel
that pill drop that eyedropper and
subsequent they feel that too scrape
that tongue borrow that leap floor from
urban exercise that melanoma fought with
that sand paper jam that zipper scroll
past those recommended conspiracy videos
fast that ketchup smell those roses
board that chip and jump free that four
squeeze that fat burn hibernate those
penguins and like and subscribe and
comment for the algorithm nation ball
pit kissing prank h3h3 MMA match vs.
jacksepticeye and more incredible well I
really like how YouTube makes the system
so simple to find videos of the Creator
say you enjoy another testimony was I
supposed to end the video
[Music]
like this when you wanna hit the flo
rida like Papa stop never stop run up in
a city and I'm never gonna fly tell me
when I go I'm like whenever I'm done
with this Pastor Mike the Edgar